j'arrête un plaisir de vous retrouver
bienvenue dans la COP15 à la place
Québec on est ici c'est ici que le
Québec va recevoir les États fédérés
vous en profitez de la coque 15 pour
annoncer des choses espèce menacées vous
allongez la liste vous revoyez la liste
donnez-moi les grandes lignes qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire considérable autant au
niveau phonique que fleuristique au
niveau fleuristique il y avait pas eu
des joues depuis 2002 vous ont depuis
une dizaine d'années au niveau phonique
depuis 2009 donc on recule encore plus
loin une quarantaine d'espèces en tout
et partout on vient se situer sur leur
habitat on vient d'écrire leur habitat
s'en protéger l'habitat de l'espèce on
aide en rien son rétablissement on vient
aussi déterminer s'il s'agit d'une
espèce qui est vulnérable ou menacée
selon la précarité de l'espèce en
question c'est une mise à jour si on
devait résumer donc on a beaucoup
parlées
entre un projet de condo puis les
grenouilles est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'on va plus pencher vers les
grenouilles on l'a vu avec ce qui s'est
passé récemment là sur la réussite de
Montréal à Longueuil en particulier faut
prendre acte de la présence ces espèces
là dans certains cas ça veut dire
modifier un projet dans certains cas ça
veut dire réorienter sinon empêcher le
développement qui était conçu au départ
mais dans tous les cas lorsqu'une espèce
est sur cette liste là désigner ça offre
des moyens des budgets pour le dire
autrement pour aider ou rétablissement
de l'espèce en question donc le
contrepoids face au développeurs et plus
grand qu'en l'espèce est menacée oui en
fait c'est obligé le promoteur adapter
son projet en conséquence l'objectif du
Québec comme du Canada 2030 30% de terre
protégée d'espace protégé mais c'est
souvent on a l'impression dans le nord
du Québec tous ces plus grand plus
facile dans le sud du Québec autour de
Montréal une vraie ceinture verte il y a
encore trop de terre agricoles qu'on
donne au développeurs quand est-ce qu'on
va faire un tournant là c'est très vaste
Québec 1% de son territoire c'est
presque 17000 km² donc on a accompli une
exploit incroyable au précédent mandat
passé de 10 et 17 %, mais oui on a
couvert davantage de superficie dans le
Nord à la demande des communautés
autochtones le défi puis je vous le dis
entre vous entre nous au cours des
prochains jours dans le cadre de la Coop
on va mettre beaucoup l'enfance sur les
mesures dans le sud pour établir un
certain équilibre que ce soit à travers
l'acquisition de terre privée que ce
soit à travers des terres publics qu'on
pourrait dans certains cas transformer
en air protégés mais on est conscient
qu'on doit mettre l'enfant sur le sud
pour justement bien représenter le
patrimoine naturel du Québec donc
Laurentides Montérégie Lanaudière
vraiment de mieux protéger leur entier
d'un projet symbol qui est celui des
monts kaeka dont on entend parler depuis
quelques années les promoteurs devraient
nous présenter leurs projets dans les
prochains jours c'est un projet qui fait
l'unanimité autant au niveau des milieux
économiques municipaux dans le secteur
s'est réclamé avez-vous donnez-moi une
idée de des espaces qu'on va préserver
dans le sud est-ce qu'on a une idée de
temps à temps l'objectif qu'on se donne
comme gouvernement c'est un mandat 2022
2026 moi j'aimerais bien loc en 2026 à
la fin du Mandon soit possiblement à 24
25% de protection sur notre territoire
et il restera un mandat 2026-2030 pour
aller chercher le pourcentage qui nous
manque mais l'essentiel à l'avenir devra
être dans le sud on voit le renard blanc
ça y est il est très rare les caribous
oui
vous les protéger pas en fait non on a
eu cette commission qui a déposée son
rapport il y a quelques mois avec une
entente avec le gouvernement fédéral on
a un échéancier on a une feuille de
route assez précise donc si je veux un
normalement on devrait annoncer la
stratégie caribou avec la collaboration
du gouvernement fédéral on sait que
l'espèce elle est cette fois réellement
menacées c'est impressionnant ces
conférences on va aller dans la grande
plénière rejoindre Jean Lemire qui est
un des Québécois qui sera le plus près
des négos alors à tout de suite
je vais venir bonjour bonjour ça va bien
ça va bien
alors voilà dans ce territoire onusien
est-ce que c'est pas devenu je vous le
pose à vous j'en veux bien mais trop
gros le texte doit être approuvé unanime
exactement est-ce que ça rend pas la
tâche herculéenne c'est très difficile
parce que idéalement dans un système où
on pourrait dire il y a 150 pays qui
sont pour 40 comptes vont pas parfait
mais c'est pas ça par contre ça amène
quelque chose de fantastique c'est que
une fois qu'on s'est entendu tout le
monde est d'accord et tout le monde
saigne et tout le monde avance les
changements climatiques
les gaz inflation facile à mesurer c'est
difficile à faire baisser mais c'est
facile à mesurer comment on mesure
comment dans des textes on s'entend pour
mettre des marqueurs c'est pas ça le
défi absolument absolument c'est comme
vous avez entendu parler de cette
protection de 30%. bon voilà évidemment
il y a des définitions qui viennent avec
ça et là où on a décidé de faire
différents de
ancien cadre mondial si on veut c'est
que là on se met des balises dans le
temps pour pouvoir mesurer prête en
mesure de mieux suivre parce que c'est
ça qui manquait avant donc là on est
vraiment dans des textes qui sont
beaucoup plus ambitieux beaucoup plus
précis et qui se calcule et se mesure
dans le temps comment on va mesurer
quand ça sera fini la semaine prochaine
le succès ou l'insuccès de cette
conférence là on a dit qu'on voulait un
truc aussi ambitieux que Paris
exactement comment on mesure ça en fait
c'est ce que moi j'aime appeler le
moment Montréal il faut qu'on crée ça
j'ai jamais vu moi autant de
mobilisation autant de sociétés civile
les gouvernements on est vraiment dans
une mobilisation exceptionnelle donc en
ce moment ça va pas très bien pour être
franc là au niveau du texte de
négociation ça avance très lentement
mais les petits miracles arrivent
toujours durant le cas ça va être dans
les derniers jours ça va jouer série va
beaucoup de pression et il faut
absolument pas triste qu'on
on a besoin d'un petit miracle
certainement comment ça se ferme la
délégation canadienne le Québec le minet
monsieur Guilbaud l'autre mais comment
ça marche
en fait on fait partie de nous de la
délégation canadienne dans un événement
en une deuxième bien sûr mais on a un
statut vraiment particulier puisqu'on
représente l'ensemble des gouvernements
infrastruations de la planète on est le
porte-parole pour tous ces
gouvernements-là pensez à la Californie
à l'école donc tout ce qui est état
province etc donc ça nous donne un rôle
vraiment particulier parce que on est à
la table de négociation ce que vous
voyez là c'est c'est mon siège on est là
oui exactement j'ai juste ici et donc
c'est de là qu'on intervenir vous allez
où vous vous avez aussi une place c'est
Monsieur Guilbaud
mais c'est un privilège pour le Québec
quand même et
Monsieur Guilbaud et vous est-ce que
vous voyez exactement les choses de la
même façon le fédéral du gouvernement
canadien ne peut pas décréter des heures
protégées donc le gouvernement canadien
mise beaucoup sur le leadership des
provinces et le Québec parmi les
provinces canadiennes et de loin le bon
élève de la classe donc tout ce que l'on
fait comme gay en terme de protection du
territoire c'est quelque chose que le
gouvernement canadien peut comptabiliser
son tour donc une belle une belle
collaboration c'est tout nouveau il y a
mais il y a beaucoup de monde à Metz
je repose la question est-ce qu'il y a
pas trop de monde pour s'entendre
si un jour vous avez la chance de venir
dans une de nos séances de négociation
vous avez un texte qui est à l'écran et
vous avez 196 crayons qui essaient de
bouger la virgule c'est très complexe ce
qui ne sont pas dans ce processus là
trouve ça vraiment un peu débile mais on
arrive avec un texte à la fin qui est
consensuel et c'est ce qu'elle est
important merci messieurs bonne COP15 on
va suivre ça au cours des prochains
jours puis il y aura des moments bas ça
va prolongation sûrement des nuits
blanches prenez pas de rendez-vous pour
le vin merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS bonne